[ Dramatic fanfare plays ]
[ Organ music plays softly ]
I now baptize you
in the name of...
[ Grunts ]
Ohh!
[ Rock music plays ]
Where's your God now?!
Aah!
Ohh!
[ Crowd cheering ]
Peace be with you.
And also with you.
♪♪
[ Crowd cheers ]
Ohh! Ohh!
Shh!
Blessed be the fruit.
Ohh!
My body, my choice.
What ya gonna do
when Big Ass Baby
gets cranky on you?
♪♪
Ohh!
I body slam you in the name
of the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit!
That's one big ass baby.
I get excited every time
there's a baptism at my church.
Anything that shaves 7 minutes
off the sermon is a blessing.
[doorbell rings]
Delorean, your date's here.
I'm gonna [bleep] your
daughter.
What did you say to me?
[babbling indistinctly]
Get out of here, Dad.
Okay, guys, smile for the
camera.
[upbeat music]
[light music]
I'm so wet.
Me too.
You need to change me.
It's 7:30.
It's past my bedtime.
That's one big-ass baby.
Let this be a lesson to all.
Big Ass Baby didn't
wear a Big Ass Condom and now
he's got a Big Ass Problem.
Excuse me.
I'm between you two.
Thanks.
I've got
a little one coming too.
whoo!
Hey, guys.
Kids fly free, okay?
I am an awful flyer.
This guy's phone's not
in plane mode.
Hey, this guy's phone's
not in plane mode.
Aah! Oh, man!
I get claustrophobic!
come on.
uh, okay.
I can't pop my ears! I can't
pop my ears! I can't pop--
there you go.
how long is that line
to the bathroom?
Too late.
I'm [bleep]. I'm [bleep].
[groans]
that's one big ass baby.
I was cranky because TSA
only lets you take three ounces
of formula through security,
and that's not enough
for Big Ass Baby.
excuse me for a moment,
gentlemen.
Okay, we have about
ten more minutes.
Breast.
Becky, bring me my binky.
[crying]
No.
Deal.
I'll have Frederick
draw up the paperwork
first thing
in the morning.
Thank you.
that's one big ass baby.
now that Breaking Bad
is over,
I think we can all agree
"Big Ass Baby"
is the best show on tv.
need you to roll down your
window, sir.
what?
I don't know how.
But it's really hot in here.
lean back!
I'm gonna shoot the lock!
ah!
never mind.
I just remembered I've got
a slim jim.
Gonna ask you to turn that down,
sir.
I'm sorry about that.
I was just binge-watching
yo gabba gabba.
you seem distracted.
Have you been texting?
just playing with my rattles
and stuff
Have you been drinking today
Sir?
I can't eat solids,
so yeah.
I need you to go ahead
and step out of the car, sir.
[cries]
I don't know how to walk yet.
Ah!
Where is he?
Oh!
diaper's wet.
uh-oh.
that is one big-ass baby.
you know who really loves
that reoccurring bit of ours?
The writers over at snl.